foreign
guests we have an incredible incredible
Duo I mean I'm talking about a real real
ragtag bunch of great guys we you know
him as revenge of the sis and I know him
as
Marsh and Royce welcome to Prime Time
with Alex sign I love the blimp you guys
like the blimp I love them the mother
blimp yeah speaking of where's my dead
Mom Mom are you there what do you think
about our guests they're actually pretty
famous on the internet have you ever
heard of a mom
heard of them
um the only gifts yeah did you know what
I heard Mom I heard a little thing
before this that from Sarah Gonzalez one
of the other hosts said that when our
guests came on the show you didn't know
who they were and you asked them their
names is that correct mom uh yes that is
cool so it's just funny mom we're trying
to run a professional operation and when
I book guests the least you can [__]
do in the metaverse is somehow learn
their [__] names is that too much to
[__] ask for Mom that makes language
oh yeah you're right Mom sorry sorry Mom
sorry Mom sorry Mom but just will you
not [__] up my
[Music]
Okay Bye Mom bye mom so yeah that's some
other blimp I uploaded my dead mom's
Consciousness into this blimp and she's
actually navigating us right now and
we're floating above daily Plaza the
site where JFK was assassinated so what
do you guys like Dallas so far
I didn't know was haunted but that is
pretty cool yes uh this is blimp just go
back and forth to that one street yeah
because it saves helium that way but yes
it's a very it's a helium saver we don't
want to [__] up climate change okay and
then uh so you guys are enjoying Dallas
right now I loved I love Texas in
general wow what about you Mike I I like
Texas not I love Florida more but Texas
is a nice home away from home I enjoy it
I enjoy coming out here and seeing you
wonderful folks well I love that so you
guys have already been they came in and
they already trolled me you guys I
should have a picture of my office but I
have the worst office here at the blaze
it's actually near a toilet so what do
you guys think about you know this
beautiful Studios but what about my
offices the studios here are amazing but
when you walk to his office it it 100
matches his mood there's garbage
everywhere there's boxes unopened he has
like what it looks like remember the
unfinished offices and die hard yes
that's what he's sitting at and he's
sitting there and go please don't change
anything this is exactly what you need
he's sitting with a backwards Captain
what are we doing next what is going on
he looks like Pepe Silva that's him the
entire time I love your office yes and
what people don't know is you guys have
been here and we actually filmed an
incredible bit that we're going to you
know showcase a little later we went on
a little dating Extravaganza with the
Revenge of the CIS guy so I know there's
a lot of a logs watching tonight so tell
me you know we have similar enemies in
this Internet space how do you guys deal
with all the Internet Hate I want to ask
Murs first specifically uh
I know but you always say that and I'm
not even trying to impress you it's just
like dude when they come after my family
my girlfriend's here they go after her
they go after like her family they go
after all these personal stuff it's hard
to not take it personal when they do all
these personal attacks yeah I just you
know I tend to keep the private side of
my life extremely closely guarded now
and uh it's just the way it has to be I
mean the culture's changed and I mean
like every streamer in the world has
been swatted and dogs like it's just
it's the the way the game the only way
it's going to stop is to give up and I
ain't giving up I love this I'm not
giving up my dream obviously not you
guys are dominating you guys have a
great audience great podcast but it's
like these people make fun of our dead
moms merch you know what I'm saying I
mean that's all they do they go around
and they think they're so funny because
they say oh your mom is dead well guess
what my mom's alive and she's operating
this blimp right now so suck that fat
one and we're gonna transfer your mom's
Consciousness into the Revenge of the
sis uh Studio very soon if you want that
technology you can get on amazon.com
away when they're like yeah your mom
died ah and you still have to go through
it so have fun with that yeah I got it
over with you know see that's funny and
what's also awesome and the reason why I
bring this up is you guys have an
incredible fan base of loyal fans I
started off as one of them I actually
always talk about this you know your
podcast is one of the podcasts I was
watching it's like man I want to do this
not that I didn't want to be a
broadcaster but I was like man I can do
it I can you know go on the internet and
talk about what I want talk trash or
talk nice and you guys were not afraid
of other people's opinions willing to go
and speak and that takes a lot of guts
I'm not trying to kiss your butt but to
hit that record button on your own live
podcast it's not easy it takes a special
kind of person and to build up your
audience is incredible and not just all
the wrestling signs but one of your
great uh supporters they ran into one of
my favorite people in the world uh
Rachel Levine or AKA Dickey Levine Mike
and Royce let's run this clip
hello Mike and Royce this is Admiral
Rachel Levine and I'm just saying hi and
uh Happy trans day of visibility
now that is a lot bro dude so tell me
the story behind that bro we have our
fan a fan of ours his name's Rob the
Dogzilla on Twitter shout out dogs
all the gaming on Rumble too so he he
messaged me and he goes hey uh Admiral
Rachel Levine's at the same airport I'm
at should I get a shot and I go yes get
a shout out immediately so he literally
five minutes later he goes you're
welcome and I look at that and I'm like
this is perfect so the Revenge of the
sis official Twitter said hey bro thanks
for the shout out Village invisibility
dude that happened on translate
visibility so it was beautiful we've had
a lot of shout outs but that was one of
that's the best shout out dude Rachel
Levine's and then my favorite thing is
when Rachel Levine said that they were
so happy that Rachel waited to
transition because they would not have
been able to have children and if Rachel
didn't have children they would be very
unhappy so it's great that Rachel Levine
is trying to get as many kids gender uh
reassigned as early as possible so what
do you think about all this transgender
stuff I know you guys talk about it all
the time but I think it's like some sort
of demand make new world order like like
occultic esoteric weird thing to
mastronize women and feminize the
freaking boys what's going on in your
opinion I think it's true I think it's a
it's about making us weak like making us
docile yeah like if everyone's like the
same like you know where the remember
the goo bags from South Park everyone's
just this generic pale thing you're not
gonna fight back I think that's what it
is I mean what look here's the thing the
whole demonic thing we've known that we
caught some we caught them burning
effigies in the woods and they go oh we
were just kidding and no one ever talked
about it again you know but I think it's
more oh good so I don't know if you guys
know this but my favorite uh beer is Bud
Light when you drink this beer you
immediately become a homosexual so
tonight for you guys I am a straight
male but after I take a sip of this I am
going to become a homosexual so let's
just see if this and you guys won't want
to yeah absolutely we're just going to
try this test what end do you put it in
well I mean I might rub it I'm like I
just forget it just for a little luck
I'm gonna rub it on there to warm it up
okay all right so let's try this let's
see this is now the does Bud Light make
you gay tests
here we go
oh that is so delicious oh my gosh oh my
God that is so good you want to suck
some deer I finally understand red oh my
God I want to go finally understand
we're in oh my God I'm like four times
more likely to molest again oh my gosh
I'm so gay right now what about your
dicks I want to suck on them I love this
game beer this is fun oh my God I just
went to it was thicker that's all it's
not fake oh my gosh I want just a big
black Johnson right down my throat to
chase this down with wouldn't that be
good just a little harder I just wish
there was a [__] on the can that would
be good at home look I'm on the can now
look how gay this is look this is taking
me so gay that I'm actually having anal
sex with a Bud Light y'all never seen
that you've never seen somebody actually
have sex this is gay sex with a Bud
Light so take that Dylan Mulvaney too
bad you cut off your dick and you can't
jam into Bud Light anymore but let me
tell you something this is delicious I'm
gay as hell and I freaking love it you
should use the Bud Light can to dilate
well you know that's another thing
actually on a serious note if you didn't
know this
if you drink this [__] you are gay no
but no Bud Light on set we hate this
it's okay if it gets on the cameraman if
you drink this gay ass beer
you're gonna wake up with a dick in your
butt all right so I think I figured out
why he has the office he has
but my favorite though is a Dylan
Mulvaney came out and was like getting
this deal with Bud Light and suddenly
people were like I'm boycotting Bud
Light and my only reaction was you've
been drinking Bud Light this whole time
yeah let me wash out the taste with
monster that's a way more straight drink
well I can't read the prompter what the
[__]
ing [__] everything sucks I can't read a
damn thing at least and then I wear this
mask this is my covid-19 mask and you
know what they don't [__] like this
man
yes I hate this [__] sometimes I'm
trying to do a goddamn show sometimes in
a break and stuff it's just difficult
it's just stressful and now drunk as
[__] you're not [__] wasted I'm gay
as [__] the Bud Light really turned him
into a violent game yes
why do I want more but light I need more
Bud Light please no more
[Music]
you like that look at that that's a Bud
Light fish I don't think I live Alex
Alex
okay oh that's good
that's good that's real good
well you've just been hard to the bite
in the cabinet yeah I know
congratulations by the way guys can you
tell me oh does this work I can't my
hearing doesn't work very well well now
mine doesn't either I think I broke it
all right guys here come in Alex night
show get tinnitus yeah that's fun be
tortured and I just had I just spilled
beer all over my Hermes time and I got
some glass in my monster I apologize
that's actually on purpose we were
trying to kill you okay so so great your
producers get to go home and they're
like what'd you do at work today I got
to clean up glass actually I love beer
everywhere yeah and actually
waterboarded my producer recently yeah
but that's actually funny he's been a
lot better since we did that
the animal the animal sex thing was was
very very big boys respect you for that